[Musik]
ja fast drei Monate Krieg in der Ukraine
und wir wollen uns auch heute die
militärische Lage im Osten des Landes
ansehen wir wissen dass seit Anfang
April etwa der Fokus der russischen
Offensive sich verschoben hat vom Norden
von Kiew eben mehr auf den Osten des
Landes aber und da muss man eben ehrlich
sein auch im Osten computin überhaupt
nicht voran wir wollen uns heute einmal
genau ansehen was wir gezeigt haben was
auch Russland erklärt hat was eigentlich
die Pläne waren die Pläne waren nämlich
ein mega Kessel also ein Kessel in dem
50.000 ukrainische Soldaten eingekesselt
werden wir hatten wir haben hier bei
easium den Vormarsch gesehen der sollte
in die Richtung gehen und gleichzeitig
haben wir von SAP Berisha in der Ringo
und SAP Berisha hatten wir am Anfang den
Versuch das hier hinzukriegen wir wissen
heute dass es überhaupt nicht
funktioniert hat also nicht mal mehr
nicht dieser Kessel wurde überhaupt
nicht aufgebaut man hat auch aufgegeben
von Süden vorzubekommen ein neuer
Versuch bestand dann von easium etwa
hier Richtung slobians und kann man
Torsten und vier wirklich bei du Netz
vorzurücken das war also sozusagen ein
kleinerer Kessel der hier geschlossen
werden sollte auch dieses Vorhaben hat
Russland mittlerweile so scheint es
aufgegeben und kommt da überhaupt nicht
voran und alles was wir noch haben ist
die kleine Offensive sozusagen die hier
lang geht nämlich hier einmal die wäre
doch nett und eben Lissy Chance einige
Orte wie man die da sind versucht zu
erobern und man versucht sozusagen
dieses Gebiet hier noch unter Kontrolle
zu bringen wir sehen also in diesen etwa
sieben Wochen in den Russland hier vor
vorrückt oder vor zurück versucht sind
die Ziele immer kleiner geworden und
Putin hat im Grunde kaum noch etwas mit
dem er hier als als großen Sieg
sozusagen angeben kann deshalb immer
verzweifelt eure Aktion wir sehen uns
das mal an zum einen der Terminator wir
haben das schon gesprochen dass es ein
Kampf unterstützungsfahrzeug ist bmpt
und das ob Zufall oder propagandas nicht
ganz klar wo der zum ersten Mal auch bei
Tageslicht von der russischen Armee
gefilmt wie es vorstößt hier sehen wir
diese bmpt die nämlich dazu gedacht sind
die haben das schon mal erklärt eben die
vielfanterie zu ersetzen also mit den
Panzern zusammen vorzurücken mit diesen
ganzen Systemen die da oben drauf sind
und die wurden ja zum ersten Mal gefilmt
in lukanz in der Region nur Hans
insivero du Netz da wo ich eben gezeigt
habe wo man noch versucht vorzustoßen
eben Boden gut zu machen und wir haben
das schon mal gezeigt wir gucken uns
trotzdem das noch mal genau an hier ist
bei einer Parade schon vor fünf Jahren
etwa das Fahrzeug mal zu sehen bzw bei
einer Messe und wir sehen eben hier oben
die Panzer ab der Waffen auf beiden
Seiten wir sehen in der Mitte dieses
große zwillingsgeschütz wir sehen hier
die Granatwerfer und wir sehen hier die
schweren Maschinengewehre das soll also
alles Waffen sein die ja Infanterie
ersetzen und Panzer unterstützen und
warum muss Putin infantrieren oder
ersetzen ja die Antwort ist ganz klar er
hat kaum noch Soldaten wir wissen dass
ein Drittel seiner Streitmacht
mittlerweile gefallen oder verwundet
wurde also nicht mal einsetzbar ist wir
sprechen hier von ungefähr 60.000 Toten
und Verletzten Soldaten und wir wissen
das mittlerweile freiwillige engagiert
werden aus dem aus Tschetschenien wir
wissen das immer mehr einer von Wagner
dazu kommen und das ist jetzt das
allerneueste er versucht den sogenannten
Terminator einzusetzen der eben die
Menschen ersetzen soll die gefallen sind
ob das Teil überhaupt funktioniert ist
überhaupt nicht klar wir haben es
weiterhin keine Videos gesehen dass das
auch in im Kampf zu sehen ist aber nicht
nur das ist die Verzweiflung sondern
auch beim Thema Drohnen
wir haben schon gesagt in den letzten
Tagen das Drohnen immer wichtiger werden
und auch kampfdrohen immer wichtiger
werden nun hat Russland aber gar keine
kampfdrohen die haben zwei drei
verschiedene kampfdrohen die wurden
mittlerweile abgeschossen oder sind
einfach ja technisch nicht in der Lage
hier weiter vorzugehen und insofern
möchten wir heute einmal und zwei Videos
angucken das hier ist eine Orland 10
davon hat Russland mehrere hundert
vielleicht sogar mehrere tausend das ist
aber eine eigentlich eine
beobachtungsdrohne eine Drohne die
Koordinaten für die Artillerie
weitergibt hier ein Video ist was hat
man noch nie gesehen diese Drohne wird
jetzt eingesetzt als kampfdrohne wir
sehen wie hier Granaten abgeworfen
werden hier unten sehen wir eine die
runterfällt insgesamt vier Stück fallen
hier raus wir gehen noch mal kurz zurück
warum ist es anzusehen weil es bloß ein
paar Sekunden sind also hier diese
Überwachungsdrohne der russischen Armee
wurde jetzt erstmals eingesetzt als
kampfdrohne
und wie völlig ineffizient das ist sehen
wir hier auch noch hier sehen wir
nämlich dann die die Ziele die getroffen
werden und wir können das mal einkreisen
die ukrainische Position ist also hier
wie man ganz gut sehen kann und die
kleinen Einschläge sind hier alle vier
hintereinander also keiner davon hat
getroffen insofern diese Drohne
eigentlich auch gar nicht dafür gemacht
aber er setzt sie trotzdem einen einfach
aus Verzweiflung sehen uns das noch
einmal an wie das läuft vier kleine
Granaten fallen da raus und dann viermal
daneben unten insofern das offenbar
keine große Gefahr für die Ukrainer aber
es geht noch weiter dieses nächste Video
finde ich persönlich völlig wahnsinnig
denn hier sehen wir eine weitere Drohne
eine kampfdrohne in Anführungsstrichen
der russischen Armee zu sehen ist
wie von einem Quadcopter hier etwas
geworfen wird und das muss einfach mal
ansehen was das ist
Drops na gut hoffentlich sieht man es
hier in der Mitte was wir sehen ist eine
entsicherte Handgranate die in einen
Bierbecher gepackt wird eine Handgranate
sind sozusagen die schon am Boden wo der
Stift rausgezogen wurde und die wird
dann in ein Bierbecher reingepackt damit
sie nicht aufgeht und in diesem Moment
wo der Bierbecher dann unten ankommt
unten hinfällt da ist die Idee dass der
kaputt geht jetzt sehen wir es noch mal
besser hier ist also die Granate in den
Bierbecher drin in einem Plastikbecher
die Idee ist das unten das kaputt geht
wenn die auf wenn er auftrifft und das
dann die Granate explodiert das tut sie
auch hier sehen wir an euer ukrainisches
Kampffahrzeug hier eine ukrainische
Position windstill offenbar und jetzt
sehen wir gleich die Explosion hier
einer Handgranate
da ist das passiert ja also wir Becher
und Handgranaten die hier genommen
werden um eben irgendeine Art von Kampf
drum zu haben als letztes wollen wir uns
jetzt noch mal ein ukrainisches Video
ansehen wir haben letzten Tagen immer
wieder gesagt dass mittlerweile immer
bessere und modernere westliche Waffen
da sind unter anderem diese Brimstone
Rakete dieses Video haben wir uns schon
mal angesehen die Brimstone hier fliegt
sie ab muss sie gerade getestet ist eine
britische Rakete die 20 km weit fliegen
kann und eben sich ihre Ziele selber
sucht es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten einmal
dass man sagt ja sozusagen lieber Rakete
da vorne ist ein Ziel bitte Steuer das
an und greife es an es gibt auch noch
zweite Möglichkeit dass man im Flug
sozusagen die Rakete umlenkt und sagt
okay dieses Ziel dann doch nicht nehmen
da sind Zivilisten in der Nähe oder
ähnliches sondern stattdessen bitte nimm
dir dieses Ziel das ist altes Material
was also einige Tage altes Material was
wir aber zum ersten Mal jetzt sehen ist
ganz am Ende nämlich dass die Raketen
auch einschlagen dass sie auch sozusagen
Erfolg haben wir sehen hier jetzt eine
Position der russischen Armee an einem
Bahn in einer Bahnstrecke die geht hier
lang und da stehen verschiedene Panzer
so wurde es gesagt von der Ukraine und
wir sehen gleich wie dann diese Raketen
hier einschlagen einmal da und einmal da
da war die erste und da war die zweite
und beim zweiten passiert das was wir
auch schon oft gesehen haben deshalb
gleich noch ein zweiter Kreis da fliegt
denn der Turm sozusagen von dem Panzer
hoch da ist er hier ist er in der Luft
zu sehen und wird abgesprengt also die
orkaner setzen diese modernen britischen
modernen westlichen Waffen auch immer
effektiver ein um tatsächlich auch die
russische Offensive im Osten zu stoppen
und Putin hat hier ein extrem großes
Problem
[Musik]